I'm Laura Ingram this is Ingram angle
from Washington tonight thank you for
joining us
spending while America Burns that's the
focus of tonight's angle
now the scenes you're watching are from
downtown Chicago last night where a
massive group of teens took over the
streets and you can see them climbing on
city buses it's a total chaos and it's
making residents terrified to even go
outside on a nightly basis the city of
Lightfoot as in Lori Lightfoot is
devolving further into lawlessness yet
somehow this disaster of an unrepentant
radical thinks she deserves to be
reelected so critics obviously complain
her tone is as heartless as her policies
are useless
she still hasn't addressed the heinous
attack on 23 year old Dakota Early who
last Friday night was ambushed shot
three times in the head and back and
left for dead in the street in an
upscale neighborhood called Lincoln Park
after multiple surgeries he's still
clinging to life
zero suspects are in custody
now last night the Bloodshed continued
three young children were shot on the
south side two boys ages 6 and 11 then
about a mile and a half away a
three-year-old girl This Is tragically
though nothing new at least 73 people
have been shot since last Friday in
Chicago at least 14 on Wednesday 21 on
Tuesday 14 on Monday and 24 over the
weekend
So Young Thugs they're running wild and
they're Fearless they're not worried
about the consequences and why should
they be Lightfoot won't do anything in
fact she's bound to take their side in
any dispute with the police
and then on a national level the
Democrats are similarly disconnected
from reality
tonight many of you are wondering what
happened to the America you love
there are pressing problems bearing down
on us yet they're busy doing their
abortion hustle taking expensive jaunts
to Ukraine and more play acting on the
pandemic by a President Who campaigned
on ending it
today we Mark a tragic Milestone here in
the United States
one million covet deaths
1 million empty chairs around a family
dinner table this summer There's an
opportunity to renew our efforts to keep
her foot in the gas when it comes to
getting this pandemic under control yeah
more like gas bag can you imagine what
the Press would have done if Trump had
presided over 1 million coveted deaths
now more Americans have died with Biden
in office with the vaccines then in 2020
with Trump in office without them
everything Biden touches goes bad
everything
our country is essentially leaderless on
five major issues the Border inflation
of course that includes soaring energy
and food costs and the China threat on
each issue the Administration has either
done nothing or when it has done
something it's just made things worse
the result is that the American people
have needlessly suffered to continue to
suffer their family budget their
personal safety their wages along with
our overall National Security and
stability
meanwhile a bipartisan cabal on Capitol
Hill they're spending money like there's
no tomorrow
this week our bankrupt nation has agreed
to send 40 billion dollars to Ukraine
it's a number so staggering that even
the New York Times questioned the wisdom
of the rushed allocation without serious
Congressional debate
and then there's the ongoing coveted
spending scam this is unreal
after Biden and the Democrats failed in
their pledge to shut down the virus they
want to be rewarded with a bigger covet
honey pot
22.5
billion dollars to be exact
the Heartbreak continues
all the more reason why we must pass the
covet of
legislation so we can purchase vaccines
provide testing and treatments to
prevent the outbreak from various very
other variants that may come along
the only thing we need to test for now
is mental confidence for the geriatrics
like her running America into the ground
testing
now Republicans should have strenuously
argued for zeroing out pandemic spending
but they agreed to 10 billion dollars
instead not smart not smart at all
according to Dr Marty McCrary we now
have about 95 to 98 immunity that's
circulating the United States time to
move on people
of course Democrats well we're spending
Hawks though weren't they when it came
to enforcing our border under Trump
if it means fewer illegals in the United
States they wanted no part of it and
they fought it every step of the way
we're not going to the 5 billion dollars
for the world we simply are not we're
just not willing to acquiesce to a
government shutdown and pay a five
billion dollar Ransom note they're not
getting it for the wall plain and simple
1 8 the price of the Ukraine package
and now we're getting no enforcement of
course at the border illegals pouring
across and being flown all across
America crowding our schools spreading
illness and disease working for under
Market pay
congresswoman Kat kamek spoke to one of
her sources at the border and discovered
something that will infuriate you
he has been a border patrol agent for 30
years
and he has never seen anything quite
like this
he is a grandfather
and he is saying that his own children
can't get
food baby formula for his grandkids
but he as a border patrol agent just
took in pallets
pallets
of baby formula for all of the illegals
that are Crossing into the United States
that alone should win the election for
the Republicans in November Democrats
just don't care
no one is convinced by today's staged
White House baby formula event either
that Biden did
these people are only serious about one
thing
getting you used to living with less
lowering Americans expectations
when even the Washington Post is hitting
Biden's wishful thinking on inflation
you know it's bad and it gets worse the
liberal-leaning website Vox is reporting
that Biden's bipartisan spend a loser
the American Rescue plan actually caused
a three-point jump in inflation what we
predicted of course
so skyrocketing costs are hammering
American families the Biden Brigade has
its sights on delivering relief not to
them but to Ukraine this is a complete
outrage
here's what's actually in the bill 4.4
billion dollars to emergency food
assistance assistance in Ukraine and
around the world and 900 million dollars
goes to assistance for Ukrainian
refugees including English language
services
every single Republican should say no to
this
but the Old Guard is still in charge so
they're all on board no questions asked
in fact McConnell God bless him is
leading the charge he wanted that money
fast tracked by golly
Rand Paul is the only one of a handful
of Republicans are standing up for
sanity here
my oath of office is to the National
Security of the United States of America
we cannot save Ukraine by dooming the
U.S economy if this gift of Ukraine
passes our total Aid to Ukraine will
almost equal the entire military budget
of Russia and it's not as if we have
that money lying around we will have to
borrow that money from China to send it
to Ukraine
and while we're on this subject why is
nobody in the military leadership of the
United States been held accountable for
the 13 American Service members killed
during Biden's botched Afghanistan
withdrawal or for all the failures of
ours in Iraq
trillions of dollars spent thousands of
lives lost and to what end
when is the last time America won a real
war outright
and the answer by the way is World War
II
writing blank checks the Pentagon is not
going to make America stronger
accountability will make America
stronger
we need to take care of business at home
and that doesn't include canceling oil
and gas leases that's only going to
drive up prices further
Pelosi actually went back to the future
today though threatening price controls
price gouging needs to be stopped this
is a major
exploitation of the consumer our bill
enables the president to issue an
emergent Energy emergency declaration
making it unlawful to increase gas and
home Energy prices and an exploitive and
excessive way
what would happen if she lost those
cards don't you wonder
the price controls work so well by the
way in the 1970s Nancy remember those
days meanwhile regular people suffer
President Biden he's the he's the piece
the cross of this
um if he would have opened up the the
pipeline and and not it didn't bow down
to the hyper uh climate control activist
we wouldn't be in the position that
we're in today I try to limit my travels
just um go from work to home my vehicle
takes about seventy dollars to fill up
before it used to be about 40. I said
about another month and a half before it
starts to like
like really break me
break people thanks Joe
we're now having to buy oil from
despotic regimes so you can placate the
climate crazies
the rest of you sweating it out this
summer you can all go to hell
Democrats addiction to spending and
their aversion to Freedom is a sickness
it's the product of a socialist mindset
that despises the independent Spirit of
the American entrepreneur and the
faithful core of the American tradition
if it's not covered they're going to use
climate change to lock you down and
limit your choices if that doesn't work
they're going to bleed us dry by getting
us Tangled into a proxy or an actual war
with Russia letting China skate of
course
president XI just must wake up every day
and pinch himself that Biden's in the
White House
anyone else find it ironic then when we
help make China richer China just turns
around and helps keep Russia afloat by
buying more oil and agriculture from
Russia
heck of a job Joey
for most of the last two decades the
establishment of both parties and their
enablers in the Press Corps they've
consistently placed their own interests
ahead of ours they've gotten richer
their buddies in China have gotten more
powerful and America the greatest freest
hardest working country on Earth has
been treated as a piggy bank for their
destructive plans
but my friends the gravy train is coming
to an end
every day the inflation numbers tell us
that the game is up and that their days
of printing money and wasting American
resources are running out this November
it's going to be the beginning of a new
era in which the people finally take
back their true power and once more
begins steering this country in the
right direction and that's the angle hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else